hey guys it's max addy we're gonna
compare these flagship phones in terms
of photo quality and crowned one of them
as the all-around King during these
tests we found strengths in each one of
these phones somewhere honestly quite
shocking and also some consistent
disappointments in certain areas so
stick around and let's take a look at a
wide variety of images and then I'll
share a summary at the end with some
surprising findings let's start off with
Pikes Place Market and the sign looks
best on the 11pro mainly because it is
brighter I took a shot of one of their
awesome bouquets here and died for 11pro
actually managed to get the white
balance correct of the paper we had warm
lighting inside but my preference is a
no 10 shot because of the the contrast
in the sharpness of the flowers here is
a macro shot of one of the flowers and
the iPhone has a lot more fine detail on
the paper but I prefer the pixel force
white balance and brighter look in this
shot of the Space Needle i zoomed in as
much as I could with each phone and as
you can tell the pixel for only zoomed
in eight times instead of 10 like the
others but even if I did early crop in
the picture for still has more detail
and the clouds look natural compared to
a little bit artifact T on the 11pro
and with a ton of artifacts and fake
blue sky that it added in on the note
now we have some shots of downtown and
these all look great I would say the
11pro looks the best the most natural in
terms of colors in exposure and then if
we crop in the 11pro is actually more
detailed as well the note 10 does have
dual aperture with 2.4 f-stop to add
more detail for these kind of shots but
looks like software makes up for it with
the iPhone this was an excellent time to
have an ultra white and unfortunately
the pixel does not have one and from the
other two I would choose the note
because it looks a little bit more
detailed and for the last one this is an
eight-time zoom with all of them that is
the most of pixel 4 will do and here the
pixel 4 has the best shy it doesn't have
the artifacting of the iPhone 11 Pro or
the over sharpening of the note 10 it
has a nice good looking zoomed in image
as we were walking we saw this awesomely
building being built and unfortunately
the pixel 4 does not have the ultra wide
so I couldn't capture that but between
the iPhone and the note that
- and looks better in terms of exposure
and definitely more detail with its 16
megapixel ultralight I took a portrait
mode shot here to test out edge
detection this is a kind of a difficult
scene and both the pixel and then note
did a fantastic job with edge detection
the note being the best in my opinion
but the iPhone totally failed us and
this is something we see again and again
in these kind of situations here's a
telephoto shot with a bunch of detail
and some nice colors the note 10 plus
goes a little bit crazy on the
saturation and a little bit higher on
the contrast whereas the pixel for looks
bland kind of like last year's iPhone
10s with 11pro not only having a nice
balance of colors and contrast but also
if we pop in we see way more detail
dramatically more and dies because of
diffusion in this standard shot I really
like the pixels Forest colors and
contrast it match the kind of a overcast
scene the best to real life and then I
also went ahead and zoomed in as much as
I could to capture the other side of the
water and once again when you zoom in as
much as you can the pixel for just does
the best job shooting up on the past the
11pro looks nice and bright contrast II
and the white balance is spot-on for the
snow the pixel 4 lacks a bit of contrast
and colors whereas the note the white
balance is totally off and it's a bit
oversaturated it looks kind of crazy and
flipping around I took a shot of my car
here and the note 10 got some flaring or
something on the lens there and then the
white balance is once again really off
where's the pixel for an iPhone look
quite similar but I like the extra
brightness of the iPhone I decided to
take a portrait mode shot and the pixel
fours looks definitely the best with the
least distortion that is because it uses
the standard lens and digitally crops in
1.5 times to take this giving us a
better perspective whereas the other two
the wide lens gives us Distortion
whereas the telephoto portrait shots we
won't be able to take a full part photo
with it now this shot here was
absolutely crazy with a huge difference
in terms of colors you know contrast and
quality now this was the perfect
scenario for a portrait shot with a
regular camera
it was bright outside
not too bright where underneath a tree
so we have nice horizontal lighting and
the pixel for looks absolutely terrible
the white balance is completely off the
detail looks really really poor that's
because there's a lot of detail on the
scene and it's digitally cropping on a
standard lens so it's not really
capturing 12 megapixels half of that
basically compared to the other two
which they are now if we go ahead and
crop in we see a massive difference in
detail the note 10 is better than the
pixel 4 with the white balance being
accurate a little bit of Anna salmony in
the skin whereas love and prose too warm
but the difference in detail is massive
on the jacket on the shirt we actually
see the buttons we see the fine details
in the jacket it is incredible and that
is probably because of deep fusion may
taking all the different stills and
combining them this looks more like a
DSLR style shot now the other crazy
thing is the difference in the file size
the iPhone it's also shooting JPEGs but
it is the smallest with way more detail
whereas the note 10 has a mass of 15
megabytes of file size which is going to
just eat up your storage especially if
you want to upload to the cloud your
data as well this shot here is extremely
tough we have the Sun coming out but
it's still overcast it is really dark
and contrasty I would say the note tens
looks the best I like that the concrete
here was brighter it kind of brings the
image out more but none of them really
looked great now it's time to compare
panoramas here's is the pixel force here
is the iPhones and here is the notes now
you might be able to tell that the
pixels for just looks very dark that the
name of cranes doesn't look good and
it's way over sharpened and then if we
go ahead and crop in on the left hand
side we see that the note 10 has the
most detail the iPhones a little bit
brighter and the pixel four just looks
really bad if we look at the opposite
side the iPhone was able to capture the
dynamic range of the clouds way better
than no 10 which is all blown out in the
pixel 4 which is not only blown out
but also super supersoft now time for
some selfies this one is in lower light
and I like the fact that the no time
plus brightens up the faces and makes it
look just more pleasing overall and the
same thing goes for this outside selfie
not only did the note do a really good
job on the edge detection but it also
has a nice balance between contrast and
colors it does do a little bit of skin
smoothing even with that turned off
which is kind of annoying
the iPhones looks the worst overall in
every single way and it's also cropped
in more because you can't take wider
portraits like you can with the other
two this shot of my wife is pretty much
an impossible shot because this gate has
so much different holes in it that the
phone has to cut out the iPhone looks
the worst the pixel 4 is better but
still pretty bad with edge detection and
Samsung definitely does the best job
with edge detection of random objects
taking a shot of my fancy breakfast the
no tents food shot here looks the most
appealing it automatically recognizes
what it was and optimized a little bit
extra sharpening and contrast it looks
the most appetizing
now in this latte shot it also
recognized it and made it nice and
bright but we also lose out on some of
the details in the actual latte art so I
would go for that pixel for for this
shot in this shot the iPhone is the only
one to get the white balance spot on and
the color of the wood panelling and
along with that the pixel 4 has this
kind of artifacting that is showing up
in the shadow areas in this portrait
shot I brought up the shadows a little
bit just like you were editing a phone
of those a little bit too dark and once
again we see all that artifacting and
the noise that shows up in the pixel for
shadows for some reason and that is
noticeable in the notes and the iPhones
but the iPhone looks the cleanest by far
and the note is pretty good too now
another thing that you notice is that
the pixel 4 is way more cropped in that
is because if you're shooting portrait
shots you cannot shoot the standard lens
width it has to be cropped in at least
1.5 times
now let's look at some more food shots
for this first one the note 10 just
didn't focus on it whereas iPhone 11
looks like the best balanced with more
detail for the second shot here the
iPhone 11 Pro has the most true-to-life
white balance but
I mean it looks the best the best one is
the pixel fours and the note 10 is just
over sharpened for this last one I'm
gonna give the win to the iPhone the
pixel 4 is oversaturated a little bit
too bright with a lot of compression
artifacts at the top of the image now we
have this Lambo in this underground
garage and only the iPhone managed to
get the white balance correct let's
finish off this comparison with night
mode shots and here we have this night
scape and I love that the 11pro still
makes it look like it is a nighttime
scene we have really good contrast we
have good colors we have really good
sharpness whereas the pixel and the note
to make it look too bright almost
unrealistic to HDR and then pixel has
all this artifacting especially in the
sky here's a shot with the telephoto
lens and the note 10 tries to compensate
for its lack of detail with extra
sharpening but it just doesn't look good
and it still looks too bright the Pixar
four has a really good looking image but
the iPhones has more contrast and more
details so that's the one I would choose
the iPhone 11 cannot do night mode
photos with the front-facing camera
that's why it looks the worst here
whereas the pixel 4 looks the best the
pixel also looks the best for the
standard night mode shot of myself and
then we decided to test out the flash
because yes we still have flashes and
they all look pretty terrible if I had
to choose one out try choose the pixels
but I'd have to change the white balance
the notes looks the most accurate but it
also has low contrast and the iPhones
flash is just too bright all of these
phones do a fantastic job overall the
note 10 plus has the most features
built-in with great edge detection but
the worst overall image quality the
iPhone is very natural and balanced with
the best overall image quality but edge
detection is still quite poor the shots
where diffusion was in effect looks
shockingly good and the overall file
sizes are half of the others saving you
space as well as mobile data the best
thing about the pixel 4 is it's 16
megapixel telephoto lens which most of
its wins were shot with but for some
dumb reason Google doesn't use it for
portrait shots making those lag detail
and they're also limited to 1.5 X crop I
would personally prefer an ultra wide
camera since you can always crop
to a photo but you can't always back up
enough or to get cool perspectives like
these surprisingly Google is still using
the same 2016 sensor that is inside of
the pixel 3 and 3/8 maybe that's why
shadow noise is an issue photos have
gotten better but that's all software
related so I really hope that the pixel
3 and 3a get updated to achieve the same
final quality we were really expecting a
bit more from the pixel 4 and if you
agree let us know down in the comment
section below we think that the iPhone
11 is the overall photo King and if you
want to see our video quality comparison
click that button above to subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]